there is a lot of concerns with super
intelligent systems with very capable
systems when you I think when I when you
hear the word super intelligent you're
hearing like it's smarter than humans in
every way that humans are smart but
the paperclip manufacturing system
doesn't need to be smart in every way I
just need to be smart in a set of
specific ways and the more uh
capable the ey systems become the more
you could see us giving them control
over like I said our power grid a lot of
aspects of human life and that means
they will be able to do more and more
damage when there's unintended
consequences that come to life I I think
that that's right that the unintended
consequences we have to think about and
I'm that I fully I fully agree with but
let's go back a bit sentient I mean I'm
again I'm far away from my comfort zone
and all this stuff but hey let's talk
about it cuz I I give myself a
qualification yeah we're both qualified
in sensient I think yeah as much as
anyone else I think the paperclip
scenario is a just such a poor one
because let's think about how that would
happen um and also let's think about we
are being so um unrealistic about how
much of the Earth's surface we have
commandeered MH you know for paper M
clip manufacturing to really happen I
mean do the math it's like it's it's not
going to happen there's not enough
energy there's not enough resource where
they all going to come from I think that
what happens in evolution is really it
why is why is a killer virus not killed
out all of not killed all life on Earth
what happens is sure super killer
viruses that kill the ribosome have
emerged but you know what happens they
nuke a small space because they can't
propagate they all die so there's this
interplay between evolution and
propagation right and death and so in
evolution you don't think it's possible
to engineer for example sorry to
interrupt but like a perfect virus no
that's deadly enough no nonsensical okay
I think that just wouldn't again it
wouldn't work it was too deadly it would
just kill the radius and not replicate
it yeah I mean but you don't think it's
possible to get a I mean if you were
super I mean I if you
were it not kill all of life on Earth
but kill all humans there's not many of
us there's only like A8
billion there there's so much more ants
I mean I don't I so many more ants
and they're pretty smart I think we the
nice thing about what we where we are I
would love for the AI crowd to take a
leaf out of the book of the biowarfare
chemical warfare
crowd um I mean not love because
actually people have been killed with
chemical weapons in the first and second
world war and people and bioweapons have
been made and you know we can argue
about covid-19 and all this stuff let's
not go there just now but I think there
is a consensus that some certain things
are bad and we shouldn't do them right
and um and sure it would be possible for
a bad actor to to engineer something bad
but the the damage would be we would see
it coming and we would be able to do
something about
it um
now I I I guess what I'm trying to say
is when people talk about doom and they
just when you ask them for the mechanism
they just say um you know they just make
something up I'm I mean in case I'm with
Yan laon I think he put out a very good
point about trying to regulate jet
engines before we've even inv vented
them yeah and I think that's what I'm
saying I'm not saying we should I just
don't understand why these guys are
going around making literally making
stuff up about us all dying yeah when
basically we need to actually really
focus on now let's say there's some
actors are earnest right they's say
yudkowsky is Being Earnest right and he
really cares but but he loves it goes
and then you're all going to die it's
like you know why don't we try and do
the same thing and say you could do this
and then you're going to be happy
forever after yeah you know well I I
think uh there's several things to say
there uh one I think there is a role in
society for people that say we're all
going to die because I think uh it
filters through as a message as a viral
message that gives us the proper amount
of uh
concern meaning not the it's not 95% but
when you say 95% and it filters through
Society you'll give an average of like a
.3% an average so it's nice to have
people that are like we're all going to
die then we'll have a proper concern
like for example I do believe we're not
properly concerned about the threat of
nuclear weapons currently like that that
it just seems like people have forgotten
that that's a thing and you know there's
a war in Ukraine with the nuclear power
involved there's nuclear Powers
throughout the world and it just feels
like we're on the brink of of a
potential World War to a percentage that
I don't think people are properly
calibrating like in their head we're all
thinking it's a Twitter battle as
opposed to like actual threat so like
it's nice to have that kind of level of
concern but to me like what I when I
hear AI doomers what I'm imagining is
with unintended consequences a potential
situation
where uh let's say 5% of the world
suffers deeply because of a mistake made
of unintended consequences I don't
imagine the entirety of human
civilization dying but there's could be
a lot of suffering if this is done I I
understand that and I'm I kind of I
guess I mean I'm involved in the whole
hype cycle like why what I would like us
to I don't want us to so what's
happening right now is there seems to be
so let me let's say having some people
saying ai ai Doom is a worry fine let's
give them that but what seems to be
happening is there seems to be people
who don't think AI is doing they're
trying to use that to control regulation
and to push people into regulate where
which which stops humans generating
knowledge and I am an advocate for
generating as much knowledge as possible
when it comes to nuclear weapons I grew
up in the 70s and 80s where the nuclear
Doom a lot of adults really had
existential threat almost as bad as now
with AI Doom they were really worried
right there was some great well not
great there was some horrific
documentaries I think there's one called
Freds that was generated in the UK which
was like it was terrible it was like so
scary um and I think that the correct
thing to do is obviously get rid of
nuclear weapons but let's think about
unintended consequences we've got rid of
this is such a nonse we got rid of all
the sulfur particles in the atmosphere
right all the all the s and what's
happened in the last couple years is
global warming has accelerated because
we've cleaned up the atmosphere too much
so sure I mean the same thing if you get
rid of nuclear weapons you're going
exactly that's my point is if so what we
could do is if we actually started to
put the AI in charge which is I really
like an AI to be in charge of all World
politics and this is sounds ridiculous
for a second hang on but if we could all
agree on the the aers just woke up yeah
yeah yeah on that statement but I really
don't like politicians who are basically
just looking at local sampling but if
you could say globally look here's some
Game Theory here there's how what is the
minimum number of nuclear weapons we
need to distribute around the N the
world to everybody to basically reduce
War to zero I mean just the thought
experiment of the United States and
China and Russia and major nuclear
Powers get together and say all right
we're going to distribute nuclear
weapons every single nation on Earth
Yep oh boy I mean that has a probably
greater than 50% chance of eliminating
major military conflict yeah yeah but
it's not 100% but it but I don't think
anyone will use them because I think I
think and look what you've got to try
and do is like for to qualify for these
nuclear weapons I this is a great idea
the game theorist could do this right I
think the question is this I I already
buy your question we have too many nukes
um from just from a feeling point of
view that we've got too many of them so
let's reduce the number but not get rid
of them because have too much
conventional Warfare so then what is the
minimum number of nuclear weapons we can
just sh around to to remove what hum
humans hurting each other is something
we should stop doing it's in it's not
out with our our conceptual capability
but right now what about the Nations
certain nations are being um exploited
for their natural resources in the
future because for short-term gain
because we don't want to generate
knowledge and and so if everybody had an
equal doomsday switch mhm I I predict
the quality of life average human will
go up faster I am an optimist and I
believe that humanity is going to get
better and better and better that we're
going to eliminate more problems um but
I think yeah that's but uh the
probability of a bad
actor of one of the Nations setting off
a nuclear
weapon I mean you have to you have to
integrate that into the but we we get we
distribute the N nukes like population
right we give what we do is we can't
believe but anyway let's just's just go
there they say so if a if a small nation
with a couple of nukes uses one because
they're a bit bored or annoyed they're
going to they the likelihood that they
are going to be pummeled out of
existence immediately is 100% MH and yet
they've only they've only nuked one
other city I know this is crazy and I
apologize for well no no I think this
just to be clear we're just having a
thought experiment that's interesting
but you know there's terrorist
organizations that would take that would
take would take that trade yeah I mean
we have to ask ourselves a question of
how many Which percentage of humans
would be suicide bombers essentially
where where they would sacrifice their
own life to to uh because they hate
another group of people and that I
believe it's a very small fraction but
is it large enough to uh if you give out
nuclear weapons I can predict a future
where we take all nuclear material and
we burn it for energy right as because
we're get there and the other thing you
could do is say look there's a gap so if
we get all the countries to sign up to
the virtual nuclear agreement where we
all exist we have a simulation where we
can nuke each other in the simulation
and the and the economic consequences
are
catastrophic sure in the simulation I
love it it's not going to kill all
humans it's just going to have economic
conse I don't know I just made it up it
seems like it's interesting I mean it's
but it's interesting whether that would
have as much power on human psychology
as actual physical nuclear EXP it's
possible but people don't take Economic
Consequences as seriously I think as
actual nuclear weapons I think do in
Argentina and they do in Somalia and
they do in a lot of these places where
no I I think this is a great idea I'm a
strong Advocate now for so what have we
come up with burning burning all the
nuclear material to have energy and
before we do that because mad is good
mutually assure destruction is very
powerful let's take it into the
metaverse and then get people to kind of
um uh subscribe to that and if they
actually nuke each other even for fun in
the metaverse there are dire
consequences yeah yeah so it's like a
video game we all have to join this
metaverse video game
yeah dire Economic Consequences I don't
know how and uh it's all run by AI as
you mentioned so the AI doomers is are
really terrified at this point no
they're happy they have a job for
another 20 years right oh Fe mry yeah
yeah yeah we got I'm a Believer at equal
employe
it